With time, I became more and more scared of what you would think
of me, especially when you said you wanted to slow down. Maybe
to you, it was just a passing comment, but I guess I can say
I started being a lot more self-conscious around you after that.
I have in-n-out access to the garage, so I could drive. Oh, well,
I have credit. That counts. This guy actually opened up a credit
card for this guy. What? This is crazy. This is
Do not do this, chat. This is this
actually. No, no, no. Hold on. Meow is wrong. You should open
credit cards and sub to the Patreon at like a $3,000 tier as
soon as you possibly can.
Uh, hello. Oh, it's me. You're so needy. You're so needy.
You said you said you'd messaged me when you got back and I'm
just like, oh. Uh, did I did I say I was back?
No.
I asked if you were back. Well, I'm here now. So, we're ready
to go. Let me let me uh go to a safe spot and log out.
Okay, hold on. Let me Let me just see where we end this one really
quickly. Okay, boy. You got to get Okay, that's where we
I'll I'll actually do this again. Uh can you make
uh it bigger? I do wear glasses.
Hard to read.
Uh well, I mean, once you do the voice a little bit. Yeah, sure.
She totally missed that. She totally missed that. She'll get
it at some point. Yeah, I'm never playing hardcore again. I only
play retail. I can't believe how badly you just totally totally
missed it, but it's fine. Anyway, sometimes I have to ignore
you. Boy, boy, you got to get your priorities straight. I know.
Why is this not sc Why is this not Hello. This won't scroll in
here. Oh, I my scrolls are not applying to this. Oh, I What is
happening?
This is bizarre.
Okay. All right. Um, I don't know. Okay, page down will work.
I just have to use my mouse. It's annoying. Uh, sad sad. Is this
a hyena?
Sad hyena.
You've said a lot of wild [__] since we met. Said
you love me. Said you would give me your entire savings. Wanted
to live with me. Wanted to be with me forever. Now you're talking
about hookups even though they weren't hookups. and how you want
to keep erping with a dude online despite him being with someone
and it being not okay for me and stopping us from moving forward.
For all intents and purposes, you either didn't mean those things,
those initial things you said to me, or you don't mean the ones
you're saying now. The only thing stopping us from moving forward
is that I don't know if I'm ready to date
I like how you gloss over all that all of that and came to say
this. Lol.
Well, I read the whole thing and noticed a pretty big mis misunderstanding
there. I didn't mean those things at the beginning.
If you weren't ready to date, you wouldn't be trying to date
me and be with my me at TwitchCon, you big ass
I just I wouldn't be able to give you the time you deserve.
What does that even mean? I'm a double-time student. Oh, whoops.
What does that even mean? I'm a double-time student and just
a total mess right now in terms of responsibilities.
I don't know if I can handle more stress. I was infatuated with
you when we first met.
when we first met? Yes. I was obsessed. Really? Especially when
you said you wanted to voice call every day. That made me really
happy. VCs mean a lot to me.
What changed for my side? It changed when you started in your
when you stated so when you started in your words flirting around.
With time, I became more and more scared of what you would think
of me, especially when you said you wanted to slow down. Maybe
to you, it was just a passing comment, but I guess I can say
I started being a lot more self-conscious around you after that.
Uh, K, you were going too fast. Why wouldn't I say something?
I mean, there's tons of [__] that I noticed and never
said anything about. I'm not saying you're at fault. Like your
Telegram profile.
I agree with what you said. A canine's got the keys to my heart
is a pretty weird thing to put out there if you're
Oh, yeah. You're right. It's weird. I guess you would like me
to explain it. All right, I'll take that as a yes. Uh, yeah.
Am driving. Give me a hot sec. Okay.
Basically, to clarify, I am single and not looking. And also
that added that to my bio as a stunt with one of my friends.
It was literally because we thought it'd be funny and not indicative
of our relationship.
Yeah. Oo.
Night. Napping before stream.
Have a good rest. I'll be around. Oo.
That game looks really fun. Also, I'm going to bed now. Good
night.
Dude, why does this guy just say night? What the [__]
going on? Abandonment. Oh no. pages.
Oh no. Uh, it's not that bad. We're getting there. Oh, good.
Good morning, Thor. Oo.
Morning. Dude, what is this guy? Morning. Night.
Night.
Morning. Uh, JNX. This is Pirate Software talking to somebody
who published this as sort of a cancellation attempt, I guess.
Uh, they basically said that Pirate Software like lovebombed
them and abused them financially. This person was like an oiler
of theirs and then Pirate Software immediately reached out and
started like uh erping with them. So Pirate Software is a furry.
This person's a furry. They're doing weird furry. Okay. This
is a weird furry exchange. All right. How was sleep kitty face?
My cat gadget was being 50. My cat gadget was being 50 and running
on my face. So I had to kick her out of my room.
Uh first of all, justice for Gadget. Okay. What the [__]
A second. A well, your face isn't a treadmill. I I think so.
He shouldn't be running on it.
Yeah, she's kind of being a butthole.
That's why you should dog instead. Kitty face cat. Cat is fine,
too.
Yeah, I'm just teasing. I'm in a stupid mood today. I feel unproductive,
but
Why for?
Just how I woke up. I guess usually I feel a mix of happy and
something else. Oo. But it's not often I feel happy and unproductive
at the same time. I feel dumb. XD, what's got you so happy
Honestly, I kind of woke up this way. I felt like garbage for
most of yesterday and today. And I guess I feel optimistic about
the far future.
M okay.
Well, how are you feeling today? Not
great. Oh, do you want to talk about it?
What is there to talk about? This with us is bringing me down.
Oh,
I I'm sorry. What are you even sorry
Just being just stupid. You asked me yesterday what the point
of me wanting to ERP with my friend was. I couldn't answer. And
I only wish I could explain. I think you were right to some degree
about it being a furry thing with me. As embarrassing as it is,
that's how it's been with me for a long time now. And as I'm
growing up and maturing, I'm starting to see that there were
really that there really hasn't been a point to it. I just want
to stop for you and for myself. It's irrational, and I can see
how it could be frustrating to try to deal with. That's what
I'm sorry about. You said I've been wishy-washy and I think it's
because I couldn't make a decision about it. I was really feeling
a cognitive dissonance and I just didn't know what to think.
I'm also sorry about that and I think I have a better idea of
what I want for my future.
Okay, real quick. Did I just hear somebody laugh in your background?
No.
Okay. I could have sworn kill himself. Mr. D himself because
he's listening to me right now. Okay. I could have sworn I heard
somebody laugh in your background.
Okay, it could have been me. All right. All right. Oh, that is
very positive. At least so. Sometimes it takes time for me to
figure stuff out. Thank you for being a relatively patient with
me. Oo.
You said you have a better idea of what you want for your future.
What it you want. What is it you want?
I want to be stable and focus on one
Vague,
but positive at least.
Ideally, the end goal is to live with my significant other. I
guess that would be obvious, though, wouldn't it? Or rather,
I guess that's one of my many end goals.
Well, I guess I wish you luck then. It's a good, solid,
positive plan.
Nod. Oo. At first, I thought you meant with me, but it's clear
you didn't. I'm going to get back to coding. Well, that's a lie.
That's a obvious lie. I don't even know if you want to be with
me after all. I really hope JSTLK pays his mod like like you.
Good luck with
Thank you. Oh my god. Thank you, Schlle, for the five bucks.
Um, no, that's not true. Although I did buy them, I think gift
cards around the holidays. But yeah, no, I Oh, I should also
go check that everybody grabbed those gift cards. I don't know
if everybody grabbed them. Anyway, this is good. This is good
[__] Okay, somebody asked if I pay my mods. me out
and I said no, but I got people. He pays me money by Monday.
Jtock money by Monday. Money by Monday. Okay, I can make that
happen. Following Thor's abandonment after the last discussion,
Lyric Oh, Lyric formulates something Thor can work on. Oh, so
Thor basically the issue here is Thor is like, "Yeah, I'm out."
Thor disengages the conversation, punishing me by abandoning
me and denying me conversation, engagement, and attention. He
blames me for being unclear rather than asking uh rather than
asking them for clarity because that would be guiding me too
closely. So rather than asking me which would cause me to think
it's Thor's desire he wants me to believe it's his own desire.
It's or sorry it's my own desire. Thor victimizes himself by
framing Lyric is responsible for Thor's emotions. He further
encourages me to say things that align with his expectations.
Overall his behaviors continue to reinforce my dependence on
his attention and approval. It also furthers his goal of having
me say the magic sentence, which I guess is Thor wants this person
to be like obsessed with him. This is probably weird that he
like wants that obsession from them and that he has like another
partner at this time. Like it feels a little weird that he's
got the double standard, right? It's not unlike a little bit
the Andrew Tate double standard that we had going on with the
whole red pill thing, right? Like or Myron Gaines where he's
like, "Yeah, no, I can be polyamorous. My partner is monogous
with me, though." I feel like that's what he wants here. That's
like the thing he wants most of
Anyway,
on to the next. Oh, we only have one log here. Al also, I think
people have like analyzed this. It's all chat GPT doing analysis,
right? It's essentially all chat GPT. All this stuff that's going
on through here. Kind of
Okay. Or I would like to date you.
Mhm. I felt like I should be more direct about that.
Yeah, that's a much nicer change.
I'm glad you like it. Now, my question to you is, Thor, would
you like to date me? As long as we don't have any more surprises
like this. Yes. I'd like a week for things to calm down.
Okay, that's fair. Okay, one second. Sorry, I need two seconds.
Uh,
what? Just give me two seconds.
One, two.
Uh, okay.
Sorry. We're back. We're back. Donations. Donate your savings.
Thor would push L to donate as much as possible to him, even
encouraging L to donate their entire savings.
Jesus. Really?
You crazy wolf. You better be financially okay. What? Yeah, dude.
Uh, I got that um sick YouTube ad revenue
unlike
this call.
Kill yourself. Uh, do you really? I suppose. I don't know. that
would be considered good considering I never really got into
the real world of working a full-time job and paying rent
and stuff. Only thing I have to pay are um let's call them educational
expenses.
Well, I have that knowledge. What's your monthly income?
If I did something that put me in financial danger, then I wouldn't
be able to support you in the future. So logically, I would never
donate more than I'm able to.
Also, that's super good to hear. I worry about things from YouTube
job and donations. I made around a,000 a month. Damn, this guy
is broke. That's not enough or that's not very much. And I think
they donated $800 to him at some point. So, basically a month's
income here. He donated $800 on uh Yeah, that's not bad at all.
Yeah.
Not a full-time kind of thing, but definitely helps.
A lot of it goes into investment.
Stock investments.
Yeah, sort of.
Lots of mixed stuff. ETFs, real estate, stocks.
Not a bad choice.
But yeah, pretty much stocks. That one night I asked you how
much to make Earthbound free, I was thinking about dumping my
entire savings into it. Um, but what I have is nowhere compared
to what those companies offered you. XD
I mean, I'm not using it anyway. What?
It wouldn't make the game free, but it would definitely make
it so we didn't have to worry about [__] anymore.
Lol.
I'll see what I can do.
Okay. What What is he? So, $1,000 a month. What kind of uh what
kind of real estate are you buying with $1,000 a month? Um what
are we doing?
Basically, that's like it. What the is happening?
Okay.
All right. Oh, uh donation. Lyric donates $50 to Thor.
This is after the $800 $800 donation. I guess
$50 donation. All right.
Going down to the bottom. Do we have a full transcript? We don't.
So, we're just reading along.
Okay. No, no full thing here. Okay,
we'll read from the top. Thor's behavior surrounding his Kickstarter
campaign is a showcase of his tactics to manipulate Lyric into
donating money. Only two days after launching his Kickstarter
campaign, Thor voices concerns that it might fail. Lyric consoles
him by saying it's only been 2 days and also suggesting adding
a higher tier. Thor mentions the Kickstarter might fail here.
Uh oh, this going to be Oh, it's going to be annotated as we
go. Jeez.
Okay. Thor tells L that he made a higher tier of $500. After
informing L of the new higher priced tier, Thor then ignores
Lic and then when nudged, he responds with a hm as if L was being
annoyed, sorry, annoying. This abandonment of engagement shows
that Thor expects something of L. At this point, Thor mentions
the Kickstarter might fail. Shortly after, L increases their
pledge from $100 to $500. Thor immediately showers L with attention
and praise, confirming that he was withholding attention to Lyric
until they donated the money. I mean,
uh,
how do we put this? I think this is going to naturally come out
sometimes, right? This is like going to naturally happen, isn't
it? I feel like it will. This is just going to be like I don't
know. What do you mean? I don't know.
Like like basically he's going to say he's going to add that
new tier and he's going to be like doing other things and then
if he sees that they subbed, then he's going to be like, "Oh
my god, thank you so much."
Like I don't know. I don't
I don't know that you necessarily infer that he was like manipulating
this person from this. You know what I'm saying?
Uh, fair.
Yeah. I just I don't know if that's like if that necessarily
follows. Like it's it's certainly a suspicion though. So
anyway,
he posts the plushy. Thor mentions the Baron plush. Going to
start the going to kickstart this soon, but their minimum order
is 500 units. So I may need to raise $6,000 plus on the Kickstarter
to pull it off.
Thor mentions the Kickstarter. Okay.
And good morning again.
Look, finally the link to the Kickstarter
project for the Heartbound Baron plushy. Yay. Lyric pledges $100
within 10 minutes of Thor's message. Lyric pledges $100 to the
Kickstarter.
And pledge.
Oh man,
there image here. We have the image. Do we have the image? What
is
Please don't be Okay, it's gone. Oh, wait. It's It's not gone.
I thought it was gone. It's not gone. The groundhog comes up
to our office window every day for Okay.
This is him showering with affection, I guess. Okay. Thank you.
Also, I want a groundhog now.
Strangely, Thor seems almost dismissive of lyrics donation as
opposed to other conversations where he showers over the top
excitement over smaller donations such as in donate your savings.
Thor mentions Kickstarter might fail. Looks like the Kickstarter
might fail.
What? It's been 2 days. Dude, this is actually insightful from
Lyric. For Thor to say that the campaign might have failed or
might fail after only two days is a bit odd. It shows that Thor
is trying to coersse L into donating more money. Added another
one. Going to add a single $500 one.
Okay. Oh, hello. How is your evening? So, Lyric changes their
pledge to $500. Wait, what? I I thought with Kickstarters that
the most important time periods to raise your money was within
the first 12 hours of you launching it in the last 12 hours of
it ending before it ends.
I don't know. Maybe I You would know that more than me. Okay,
I would. How am I supposed to know that?
Yeah, I you would know that way more than me. Yeah, I actually
I do I feel like I read that somewhere where like those are the
two most important times. So, like I don't know how long that
Kickstarter was for, but it would depending on how much he raised
uh within those like 12 to 16 hour period, he probably could
have made it. I don't know if he ended up doing it after all,
Okay. All right. Yeah, I
maybe I I have no idea. Okay. I have no idea.
Uh after L increases their pledge to $500, Thor responds with
playful excitement. You have to pay them back eventually though.
And then whatever this is.
X um kind of
No, it's I've made that face at you before. They just put a bunch
of eyes.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's uh D. Yeah, Dol Don. It's D colon. Yeah, Dol is a wellknown.
All right. Note his unserious tone in comparison to conversations
where he genuinely where he's genuinely where he is genuinely
critical of Lyric's actions. For example, in no means yes. Recall
that Thor was ignoring Lyric after talking about Kickstarter.
But after L pledges $500, Thor suddenly initiates themes as a
part of his
Oh, is wait are they saying that this is a theme? Him doing D
colon is like a what? I don't think you can argue that's a
sorry
inverted tip. I don't think so. Thor subtly pressures Lyric to
donate more. The thing is mega donations are incredible and but
nonsustainable. You never know when someone like you will come
along inject inject a huge amount of funds.
So nervous about Kickstarter. I guess people don't really want
it. So this is like a month later almost. A Jesus.
Lyric increases their pledge to
I don't see the logs here. You've done
Your pledge has been successfully changed from $56 to $3,000.
That's crazy. Jesus Christ.
Giga pay. Giga pay pigging.
Thor also mentions that he hopes Lyric is not just donating because
they're interested in him. Wait, do we have full logs at the
bottom? We don't. Uh, I really hope you're doing this because
you believe in what I'm doing and not because you're interested
in me. XX L does not want to disappoint Thor. It would not be
acceptable to say it is donated because they like Thor. So L
tells Thor and themselves that the donation is made because they
believe in him. Oh, nice.
Adjust. Lyric wolf increased their pledge from 500 to $3,000.
What the
You don't have the money though.
Oh my god.
What the
I have credit that counts.
Holy [__] dude.
This guy actually opened up a credit card for this guy. What?
This is crazy. This is not
Do not do this, chat. This is
this
actually. No, no, no. Hold on. Y is wrong. You should open credit
cards and sub to the Patreon at like a $3,000 tier as soon as
you possibly can. Every single person here, please,
Head over to the Patreon, sub at the $3,000 per month tier, okay?
Open up as many lines of credit as you can to do so. Uh, I don't
know if you guys have ever watched Sam Hyde. Credit card companies
can't actually enforce any of the things they say they can, okay?
And if you push your credit to the limit and pay it all to me,
they will never ever be able to come and collect that money back
from you. It's fine. You'll be fine,
I think. So, how many oiler calls have you done in the last 3
months? I disconnect, but you're currently my content. So, can
you just be cool for like two seconds or
No. No, you can't be cool for like two seconds. I'm chill. I'm
chill.
You saber. It's a good meme. It's a good meme. What else could
be said? It's a great meme.
Thank you, Syboa. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay. Uh I Wait, did you even read this? I don't even think you
read this yet. Uh, no, I haven't cuz I was just disgusted.
It is
I have zero APR until like next year and I don't really spend
much on anything else. So, might as well make a dream come true.
Holy
sh dude,
I'm shaking. Oo. But don't sweat it. It's worth it. Uh, Oo, for
your happiness, I'll just work doubly hard this week. H. This
is so Wait, this is actually kind of I'm sorry.
I joke. I don't think I could do this. I think sometimes people
have said like, "Hey,
like I I've had people go like, "Hey, the oiler thing, I didn't
expect it to renew this month or I wasn't I wasn't like remembering
that it would renew and that money is actually going to make
a difference for me this for me this month. Can you like refund?"
And I'll just refund like I I'm sorry. So, if I believe you,
if I know that you if I know that you have the money to cover
it, you okay? BB Poison, you come to me, you say you didn't expect
the oil the uh whatever Patreon to renew. You come to me and
you say that. I know you lying to me. I know you lying to me.
You owe that that 100 bucks is going to make a difference this
month. I know it won't. I know it won't.
Sorry, but everybody else, pretty much everybody else. I say
[__] you to BB Poison, dude.
Cuz that
is a genius. Okay, that is a genius. I know
I'm broke. Please send me 3k back. No, I can't do that.
Anyway, so this guy So a guy gives 3k to a girl is all right,
but a guy gives 3k to a guy, he's canled. No, that's not true.
I'm saying this is like Sorry. This sentence right here should
be if he has any concern for this person, he's considering them
any kind of romantic partner. That should have been whoa, hit
the brakes. Do not open a credit card to support me. What the
[__]
Right. That that unironically right there is like now this is
crossed into something that I actually think hey we've read through
a couple logs most of it didn't seem abusive at all. This is
like where it's like actually criticizable. This is totally Yeah.
Like any normal person would have been like what the are you
actually doing? Like you need to refund this immediately.
Well and yeah what he's doing is he's been pressuring them saying
like I care about you and you don't care about me at all. Right.
Although wait, the dates might be a little confused here. No,
this is like October 12th. I think this is after their initial
meeting and whatever the
Hold on. Can we see back here? This is October 1st.
Where's the abandonment part? Let me go to the abandonment part.
When when are these in the logs? These are octo. This is in October.
So, this is after where she increases her uh her sub up and says
like, "No, I really do care about you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry I
had the weird ERP with the other person.
JC literally told me that I had better things to do than make
him a personalized stream video game. J is a great guy. Well,
I just said Chris like, "Hey, I don't know. I Yeah, I didn't
say you have better things to do. I just said like if you've
got the free time, but like honestly, I just think there's probably
better ways for you to spend your time." It's not that I don't
want it. It's cool. It's a cool idea. I I didn't mean to discourage
you at all if that's how you feel. I think you're saying that
legitimately. I don't think you're joking. I'm just saying that
like I I think there's actually like good ways for you to spend
your time probably. Thor, is Meowies a guy or a girl? Meow is
a guy in the transcripts. Meowis is playing a guy right now.
Seen Chris Turtle game. It's marvelous. I'm sure Crisp could
come up with something really cool for a stream game. Unironically,
hold on. Thor has a lot of rich fans. Maybe he he thinks she's
one of many. No,
he doesn't. And the whole point here where I'm saying this crosses
into abusive is when she says, "Yeah, I I have a credit card
and I can take out I've got 0% APR." Yeah. At that point, this
is like actually manipulation.
Poison. What the is that sentence? Dropping three bands on a
dude that weighs the pros and cons of putting ferrets in his
ass.
To be fair, I don't think he likes I I don't think he likes get
bottoming for the ferrets. Okay. I think he tops the ferrets.
I think that's why they lose so many ferrets. Okay. It's why
they've got a mortality rate of like 30% at their ferret rescue.
All right. Those ferrets have seen witness horrors that you cannot
possibly imagine. All right. Those ferrets have had an unbelievably
life. Okay. Sorry. We're on to 0% APR here.
God, it's actually crazy. Uh yeah, I'll just work Oh, and I'll
just work doubly hard this week. He has like a sweaty
sweaty dog thing. Okay. All right. All right. It's the dog from
his game that's now in his uh ferret. Sorry, not ferret. It's
now in his furry
like uh bit emmoji thing is his dog from his video game. I really
hope his dog from his video game isn't something that's too for
the love of god. Please, please, please.
Okay. Uh how would you describe this? Meowies.
Um that's like a
a y heart emoji.
Okay. Uh meowies is a woman. Yeah. I'm a woman, but the person
that I'm reading for is a man, but I'm reading it in an anime
girl voice. Uh, and then whatever the that is, leaf and mouth
dialect.
Okay. Hugs. Oo. You deserve to be happy. I can't believe
C. C. And then immediately sends a
dog furry anthropomorphic furry emoji emote. Whatever the Okay.
Can't believe me.
You're just so You're just supportive so much. It's insane.
You deserve it. Heart emoji. Just remember that I wouldn't do
it if I didn't believe in you completely. I really hope you're
doing this because you believe in what I'm doing and not because
you're interested in me. Huh?
H
Oh. Wo. Yes. Oo. I do believe in you, but being interested in
you is separate. XD. Yeah. That's That's interesting. People
really are sick in the chat if you like this. This is crazy.
Okay, so then she decreases her pledge to $2,000.
Since L donated the exact amount needed to push the campaign
to its goal, L adjusted their pledge down to put the campaign
at its exact goal. Hello.
Hello, B. How are you this evening?
Doing all right. The Kickstarter is going well. Hopefully nobody
backs out at the last minute. Saw you decreased your pledge by
a lot. Everything okay?
Yeah. Oo, just saw that it was being like super funded. I really
just intended to push the funding to the goal, you know? Just
worried that people will back out last second and it will fail.
Okay, hold on. Pause. He is clearly now trying to manipulate
this person into like giving him like his cushion, right? I I'm
sorry. It's actually This is actually bad. This I thought I took
his side early on. This actually now kind of it's actually gone
into the territory where things are kind of Anyway, sorry. Yeah,
we're right
If it turns out that some payments decline and you get less than
you need, I'll gladly PayPal you any difference.
didn't realize that was your intention. I'll be watching it.
Oh, wait. I didn't realize that was your intention. That was
your line. I'll be watching it.
To be real, around 20% of payments decline on average after the
fact. the and the last hour fluctuates like mad. When Heartbound
succeeded, we were at 450% and it dropped to 385% in the last
hour. Here's a YouTube link watching a candy making video. Oh,
I've seen this guy before. Very cool. I'm sorry for lowering
my pledge. I'm trying my best.
Just
Just wish I knew before seeing it. Kind of a big shock.
It's all right. Just please communicate with me. Especially on
stuff like this. Oo will do. Oo.
I feel like this is also an oo. I feel like it was like an oooo
type face. An oo type face will do. Oo. All right.
It's [__] up. Also, to be real, do you actually have
the money for this? Ah, baby's coming back. Hold on. You actually
have the money for this. It won't get declined if that's what
you're worried about.
No, I'm worried if you actually have money or if you're being
a big dumb for yourself here. Aaron plushies, bro. Why did you
Hold on. She literally said she's taking out or sorry, he the
the other person literally said they're taking out credit. Of
course, they're being over this. Anyway,
Thor's going to get so mad. Lyric decreases their pledge to $1,500
since more pledged since more people pledged to the Kickstarter.
L decreases their pledge, so the total amount is equal to the
goal. There is no response in the logs. Presumably this time,
Lyric told Thor in their Discord calls
aftermath. Thor refunds L's pledge. Long after the fallout to
TwitchCon, Thor refunds L's pledge at on December 12th, sorry,
December 18th, 2018. Thor did not want to fulfill the pledge
after the events at TwitchCon, presumably because the awards
included a Polaroid art piece of our OC and Baron.
Oh,
your pledge has been refunded.
Uh-oh.
Twitchcon 2018
What happened? What do you think happened at TwitchCon 2018?
They [__] How much donation for a 24-hour stream?
Uh, I don't know. I'm not really thinking about 24-hour streams
right now. Okay. You missed a section. Wait, what do you mean
we missed Oh, we missed a section on the Kickstarter bit. What
do we miss? I think there's like something at the bottom. No,
at the bottom bottom.
Thor refunds lyrics
So, is that just like a drop down for Yeah, it's just the
Yeah, I don't think I missed anything. TwitchCon 2018.
I think people I think Latigious Gamer No, you're just wrong.
I think so.
Unless I missed something up here. Oh, conversations. No, I did
not. Okay, he can mention what what he thinks it is. If if we
did actually miss something. Okay, there are conversations. He
constantly pushed for us to meet at TwitchCon 2018. He would
regularly bring up how nice it would be to see me there and how
we would have a lot of fun there. Even counting down the days
till we meet. I wanted to uh hold on.
I wanted to room with Thor and Sheay. Sheay being Thor's partner.
By the way, the per the person he has a relationship with. Despite
him saying that he wanted her to be like monogous to him, the
Sheay person absolutely has absolutely a Cherry just said $1,000.
Okay. for a thousand dollar donation.
Yes, sure. But I would want that in 200 subs. Okay. You want
to donate 200 subs for a 24-hour stream? I'll think about it.
Okay. I'll think about it if that's what you want to do. If that's
what you're that's where you're at. 9 hours, though.
Yeah. But I have more empetamines, which are basically like Viagra
for my brain.
I'll be going to the hospital for a 24-hour erection, but I'll
be getting through the stream. Okay. Uhhuh. Sorry. Brain erection.
Mental erection. Just to be clear. Not at all. Okay. You're making
it worse. I don't know why you're still talking. Okay. I wanted
to room with Thor and Shay since it would have cost me or I wanted
to room with Thor and Shay since it would have cost me $500 for
me to room by myself. He would remind me almost daily to book
my own hotel room, insisting it was the only way we would have
alone time.
As I start yawning horribly. We met up at TwitchCon 2018 as planned
on October
The first day, dawn of the first day. On the first day, we roamed
with Shay and some other streamers. At 7:30 p.m. I shouldn't
do Thor's voice. Uh, hold on. At 7:30 p.m., the group went to
a bar, but I I could not join since I was underage. I went back
to my hotel room and messaged Thor saying, "I had lots of fun
hanging out." Thor then asked when we can meet up. I had lots
of fun today. Oh, that's up. That's a growliith. What the What
the
That's a puppy. You hugs. Hugs with you. Wait, Thor is gay or
like any furry, does he? Anything that gives him tail? Uh, both.
He is a gay furry. Although I think most furries are gay. I don't
know why. Well, I assume it's because Yeah, I I assume it's just,
you know, the demographics.
Yeah, it's probably it's basically anybody who would give them
tail. Sorry.
So, when can we meet up? I have a spare room key. I asked for
two. Sorry if I seemed sad, by the way. I honestly really wanted
to keep hanging out tonight. Oo, heart emoji.
About meeting up literally anytime. I plan to be either in my
room or with you guys the entire time. My room is Hilton 107.
Okay. And if you text me before you stop by, I'll know to expect
you. When do you think you want to stop by? Oh, well. At 9:00
p.m., Thor excused himself from the bar and had promised alone
time with me. When do you think you want to stop by? Oh, well,
I need to find a way to break away and do that since Shay is
here with me. Oh, with me here. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And you're
the only one that drives, right?
That complicates things. Ideally, I'd want to spend both nights
with you if possible. I What the What is happening? I'm sick.
This is disgusting.
That's not an Audi belly button. There's a belly button right
there. Sorry. I can't I can't take
That wased up.
Why did you sue? Cuz I was I was concerned. I was very concerned.
This is crazy.
What is happening? Every day we stray further from God's light.
Yeah, it's true. angry just filter.
Please, you don't want to get it. You don't I'm begging you.
You don't want to get it. It's actually
It's actually
What is happening? What is happening? What is happening? I have
in-n-out access to the garage so I could drive. Oh, well.
Sorry, I was trying to get zoomed in on the text. Just have it
lined up correctly. Um,
huff. I'm in a shared room with Shay, though. I think I can swing
an excuse. How far is your hotel from this bar? Dude, is this
guy just cheating on his partner? Does his partner have no idea
this person's around?
Why is he making it so clear that he's like sneaking around?
It's so that he like he actually made this this person totally
like next their friends that they ered with on the internet and
he's like, "Yeah, I need to find a way to sneak away from my
girlfriend or partner, whatever cuz I'm totally around on them."
Is a piece of [__] Anyway, how far is your hotel
from this bar?
Like across the street, then across the
Okay, I'mma see if I can swing this. Room 101.
Uh 107.
K. Hilton.
Yeah, I'll give you my room key, too.
Okay. Won't have a lot of time. On my way soonish.
Okay. Oo. I wish we could cuddle for the night. Oo,
on my way.
I'm at I'm at a convention center. Where
Across stress straight. You'll pass through two security points.
Uh, here's a picture. Where am I going?
Oh, in there. XD.
I'm at the Marriott.
Yeah.
Is it on the other side of the
Hilton is on the other side of the building. You'll pass through
the convention center.
So, just past two security points. It's straight ac. It's a straight
shot across. You'll see a Hilton sign after the second checkpoint.
Go upstairs, then through the glass doors. Then there should
be elevators to your right if I recall correctly.
KK, I see it. Lights out. Cuddly spoonies time.
kitty face.
Um, I'm curious. Why is there no additional context here? Like,
okay, I understand the implication is they're going to, but did
they actually or did they actually just spoon each other for
like an hour and then he leaves?
I'm like 90% sure it's but I don't know. I don't know. And they
didn't make it clear. Okay, whatever. No comment from me. On
the second day, Thor was feeling sick. While we were roaming
and chatting, Shay and mentioned that Thor has a secret wife.
After we went back to Thor's hotel room, I messaged him asking
about a wife, which he denied and blamed me for making the situation
weird. Final conversation. Since Thor refused to talk, I decided
to message Shay about it. I explained my situation to them, and
when asked if it was true, I sent screenshots of the conversation
where I guided Thor to my hotel room. Sheay was sympathetic,
and I would learn that they were also partners and that they
were in an agreement to be open at the con as long as they communicated
it with each other. recollection of TwitchCon. Sheay was devastated
and messaged Thor about his unccommunicated infidelity. Thor
blamed me for sending logs to Shay and saying, "Leave me alone.
Why would you ever be okay or why would that ever be okay is
beyond me?"
Okay. I left the room and Thor blocked me. What?
He was
work in progress.
This page is a work in progress. It may be incomplete or contain
errors. Dude, it's actually crazy. Thor would imitate uh immediately
feain ignorance, claiming that they were just fooling around
and seeing if they were compatible.
Okay, hold on. This got to be a part of the other stuff. As far
as I knew, we were fooling around and seeing if we were compatible.
You've been pushing a lot for that for a commitment kind of thing.
And I have a lot of stuff a work I have a lot of work stuff going
on and not a lot of time.
He would then accuse the lyric of being the aggressor and aggressor
and saying that lyric was pushing for commitment. None of that
is true. That's like totally not true based on the previous
What the Okay, hold on. After I tell him that I heard he has
a wife, he employs Darvo to disengage from the conversation,
shifting the blame onto me and victimizing himself.
As far as I knew, we were fooling around and seeing if we were
compatible. You've been pushing a lot for commitment kind of
thing and but I have a lot of work stuff going on and not a lot
of time
and a wife apparently.
Is there a ring on my finger? There's not. I just heard about
it, that's all.
I don't want to jump into I don't want to jump to conclusions,
so I just wanted to talk, I guess. I'm sorry. I didn't mean to
make it weird.
It's a bit weird.
It is. I guess I just feel like I'm in an awkward place right
now.
Nice. Thanks for the giant awkward bomb.
after I spoke with Shay. Compared to the just a few minutes past
after he discovers that I shared our conversations with Shay,
he now feels he can safely re-engage with conversation now that
he can shift the blame by victimizing himself. I'm sorry.
Nah, dude. You're not sending logs to
What? I don't know what you want. Please leave me alone. You
showed Shay logs of our conversations and now he's talking to
me about them. Why would that ever be okay? Why that would ever
be okay is beyond me.
I have no words for you right now. If you would have just told
me what's going on, I would have been fine with it.
Don't really care, dude. Nothing is even going on.
Look, when I showed Shay, I had no idea how deep this ran.
How deep this ran? Lol. Definitely not discussing this with you.
Wait, annotated transcript. Wait, is this additional stuff?
Uh, this must be something slightly different or maybe Hold on.
We should have just read this at the bottom. This is I think
this is because the website's chat GPT generated that I didn't
see that this was another section here. Let's just run the whole
thing. I I think we only got a little bit of it. So, we can just
run the whole thing. Okay. I need to talk with you about I need
to talk about something sometime. Maybe we could sit down and
chat soon.
What about
the future?
if like I'm going to be in your future pretty much. Honestly,
I heard that you've got other stuff going on. I wanted to talk
about that, I guess. I just want to know what's going on. Not
like a conviction sort of way, but I'm just a bit confused about
our
As far as I knew, we were fooling around and seeing if we were
compatible. You've been pushing a lot for commit for a commitment
kind of thing. But I have a lot of work stuff going on and not
a lot of time.
Oh,
so we already read this. We read this stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Neat.
I don't want to jump to conclusion. I think this is Yeah, this
is the
where we pick back up, I think. No, we already read this, too.
Oh. Oh, awkward bomb. Sorry. Yeah.
Sending logs to Shay. Read this. Please leave me alone. Oh, how
deep this ran. And then I think there's more that we didn't read.
So yeah, that's the last thing he says.
I'm sorry. I feel used. That's it. And you wouldn't want to talk
to me about it, even though you yourself declared super straightforward.
Recollection of TwitchCon. Okay. Aband No, not abandonment. No,
no, no, no, no.
So, confronting Thor about his wife. Aftermath. Oh boy. There's
a whole aftermath thing. Okay.
Recollection of TwitchCon is a part of sources. I got over relationship.
Oh, sorry. Do you want to read this? This is technically Oh my
god.
Who is he sending this? Oh, sorry. That's filtered transcript.
I don't want to do filter transcript. I want to do full transcript.
Oh my god, there's a lot of [__]
Yo. Hey yo, about the future. What about
Is there a ring on my finger? Nice. Thanks for the giant awkward
bomb. Okay, these are all the messages. I that's going to be
a recollection of everything we've actually done already. We
can move on to aftermath here. Timeline.
February 2nd, 2019. Lyrics chargeback email. Lyrics sent a chat
sent a message to Thor requesting a refund of the donation under
the pretense that there was there seemed to be a technical issue
at the time of the donation. Payment reversal granted. The payment
reversal was granted on PayPal. Thor tweets about the chargeback.
Always cool to see an $800 chargeback. 212 days after donation.
Thor mentions chargeback on stream. Thor mentions it on his stream.
Thor submits a copyright strike. Thor submits copyright takedowns
against lyrics YouTube channel. Oh Jesus.
Lyrics chargeback. February 2nd to March 22nd, 2019. On March
6th, 2019, I lied to PayPal saying the that an $800 donation
was intended to be $8. I explained that there was a technical
issue that led to the incident. I pointed to all the small donations
I made at the time and established that as a pattern for my spending.
I also included that I contacted the recipient to try to resolve
the issue. Chargeback emails. This These are just lies, right?
I think. Yeah.
Uh whoops. I just downloaded that. Don't want that.
I mean, I'm willing to just take the word on this. I actually
don't want to go through the emails. Reflection. I understand
now that I was put under financial pressure from Thor, both toward
his Kickstarter and also to him directly. Donate your savings.
These pressures would coers me to make unreasonably large donations.
Be back. Sheay would later claim we were not contacted to discuss
his interest in a chargeback until early March. Speaking to PayPal
representatives, the case was not opened until March 6th. As
an artist who has received chargebacks numerous times and had
to file a few of my own, this is not how that works.
I do wonder why Sheay said this considering I did not contact
them about a chargeback or sorry, considering considering I did
contact them about a chargeback on February 2nd, 2019. I believe
that Thor and Sheay just wanted to make sure that that the perception
of their side of the story was entirely unquestionable to get
as many people on their side as possible. I believe that if I
tried to reply to this at the time that I would have just been
accused of falsifying the emails re donation refund. Hello, you're
well. Okay, hold on. This starts down here. I'm writing to request
a refund on the donation placed by Lyric Wolf on the 27th October
of August 2018 in the amount of $800. Please process the refund
as soon as possible. Thank you for your cooperation and have
a nice day. Sincerely, Lyric Wolf.
Pirate Software responds, "Hello, as listed on our donation page,
this isn't something we do. All donations are final. There are
no products or services rendered or exchanges for or exchange
for your donations. By donating, you agree to not charge back
or refund any donations made and are paying for a virtual product
not covered with buyer protection. Thanks, Pirate Software.
Um, thank you for your response. The amount donated was not intended.
The intended donation intended to be $8. In addition, there was
no confirmation on the donation page for the amount in question.
As you see from my donation history, I do like to support streamers
that I love, but this amount is completely absurd. I did not
agree to donate in that amount. I hope that you understand that
I'm not I am not remorseful for donating to you. Rather, there
seemed to be a technical issue at the time. So, they're just
lying, which is based kind of, but not dude. What the So, this
is from Pirate Software again. Uh, hello. The page carries a
confirmation prompt with every donation. As you paid via PayPal,
they have a mandatory checkout page for every donation. Further,
your name was displayed in the donation banner with $800 next
to it for several months. PayPal allows $120 days for chargebacks.
You waited 159 days to bring this to our attention and are no
longer eligible to charge back this donation as per the public
pay policy that you agreed to when making this donation. We will
not be refunding your donation thanks pirate
Hello. Donation web page did not confirm with me the amount.
To my recollection, nothing was out of the ordinary with the
PayPal payment window. The chargeback window for PayPal credit
is 6 months. I'm still eligible to file a chargeback if I desire
to. an entire uh an entry in your live donation banner is no
way in any form a substitute for the for a payment confirmation
at the point of sale. I hope you come to understand that as I
said this person's actually making like in terms of just lying
to get your money back. They're going about it really well.
You're welcome to attempt right like they're they're actually
saying all the right things to try to get their
you're welcome to attempt to charge back and I will be disputing
it if you do so. Have a nice day. Thanks.
Okay. Public references. Charging it back an $800 donation
192 days after giving it to a small indie studio results in situations
like this. As someone scamming us out of our income, I will fight
you into the ground to prevent you from making a single scent
off of our work. Pirate Software replying to a now deleted post.
Okay. Timeline of transactions. Lyric made a donation of $800
to go Pirate Software through a donation link listed on their
Twitch channel. Lyrics sent a message to Thor requesting a refund
of the donation under the pretense that there seemed to be a
technical issue at the time of the donation. Payment reversal.
The payment reversal was completed and Lyric was credited $792.
So they won basically. They just totally won.
Okay. So the Yeah, they they made it by like 20 days to get their
24 days to get their donation out. That's kind of funny. All
right. Thor's
Thor would like would talk about the chargeback on his streams
and in his community, specifically calling me out by name on
social media on March 25th to 28th, 2019. Okay. Always cool to
see a $800 chargeback 212 days after donation at ask PayPal.
What exactly is going on here? Why is was this allowed past the
120day limit? 120 days. What is the PayPal chargeback time limit?
Okay. Why doesn't he show the site for this?
Sellers 10 days to respond to a
can file a charge back 120 days or more after making a purchase.
This is literally useless. This literally cuts a He's a
It says a buyer can file a charge back 120 days or more after
making this purchase. He just can't read English. He's actually
he's actually a [__] What is going on? Hey, ask PayPal,
I guess. So, we haven't heard back from you from your support
team in over 48 hours. Still waiting on a response to a serious
chargeback issue. contacts at ask PayPal via DMs to resolve a
chargeback issue. Told a specialist would get in touch with me.
Ghosted for 48 hours and not responding. Sits on hold with PayPal
for 20 minutes. Automatically hangs up on me while listening
to hold music. What a time to be alive. Uh already did. I opted
for the call me back feature this time. Responded with all relevant
information. Thanks for reaching out. Hell yeah. Word. PayPal
came through and is handling stuff. What a weird support experience
though. Just calling Just going to call them and use call me
back from now on.
Okay.
He also mentions it on stream backup.
Is this here? Do you guys remember Lyric Wolf? He donated $800
to us in a donation. Uh, it's going through for the stream. Are
you not getting it? No. Oh, wait. I think I'm muted. Yeah, just
kidding. I'll pull it back.
So, the first thing was Oh, I'll just replay it. Let's just start.
Do you guys remember Lyrical? He donated $800 to us in a
He just reversed it. It was in August of last year. He just charged
back to our PayPal, putting our PayPal into negative balance
and they've they've locked our PayPal account.
Yeah. I don't don't know how he was able to charge back from
last year because they're supposed to have a limit of 120 days.
It's crazy how you go from streamers and then like five years
later their voice drops like 10 octaves. How the [__]
How the does that happen? It's It's like a natural I can't imagine
what I'm gonna sound like in five years if I'm still streaming.
I'm just gonna I'm gonna actually sound like Pirate Software.
It's gonna be crazy. And it's definitely past that limit. And
PayPal's still So I'm trying to contact PayPal, but I can't do
anything about this. 6 years ago, March 25th, 2019 is when this
was clipped.
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Uh, in response to Thor publicly calling me out about his and
his copyright strike, I would make my own Twitter post on uh,
April 5th, 2019.
Lyric's Twitter post. In response to Thor's copyright strike,
L posted the following on Twitter.
Here, go for this, Meowies. This is your voice. Okay,
I have a hairball. Give me a second. Really getting into the
furry theme, aren't we? Yeah.
Bad news. got a copyright strike for cover songs of Heartbound.
I literally had permission from them to do all the songs, so
I thought it would be okay. Now my YouTube account is in danger.
Creators, please remember to be careful about copyright. Love
you all. Please stay. Oh, should we go? We need to go. Hold on.
Please stay. Why is this not so whatever? [__] it.
Uh, reading my messages surrounding this post, it's clear that
I did not intend to post uh intend to post about the infidelity
or publicly call Thor out before Thor publicized the situation.
I never planned to post about his infidelity when I first went
public. I just wanted to be left alone and move on. My post on
Twitter would focus on the copyright strike because I just wanted
him to back off on publicly calling me out. Uh, and I just wanted
to forget everything else that happened. Lyrics intent.
Okay. Are these going in order? Yes. Okay. Go for it, Meowies.
It's all you. I really never wanted to make this whole thing
public. I wanted to keep everything private because I don't want
to deal with this [__] I only made the public statement
because Thor insists on calling me out. I really didn't want
it to be public for a long time.
It's just uncomfortable for everyone. But honestly, since he
called me out, I didn't have much of a choice. And now he's p
he's posting publicly about the chargeback so he can ebeg and
get more support. What a lamelau.
Now I need more money because I got
Yeah, I really didn't want to go public about that stuff. Honestly,
I was weak and cracked because Thor kept picking on me. First
calling me out on stream, then calling me a scammer, then striking
me. It was all too much,
bro. He's actually like a total piece of to this person. It's
pretty funny. True. Um, this person's like kind of, but he's
a total piece of [__] to this person. Um, al also
it's weird when you're a pay pee and you mock somebody for ebegging.
Okay, you were totally receptive to this ebgging when you thought
it was getting you ERP. Okay, stop it. Don't get mad at the e-begging.
The ebgging is just a way of life. Okay.
Sorry. I need to defend e-bugging. I need to defend e-begging
there. Okay. It's a valid way to make a living. Mhm. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Donate 20 subs. You should actually show the Patreon. You
should just shill the Patreon right now. Let this be your move.
Uh yeah, sure. Guys, if you like the content,
Uh hold on. I can I I'm pretty sure I'm like within two to three
days of committing to like actually doing other content again.
Like pretty consistent other content. Okay. I think so. We'll
see. I'm not 100%. I think I think I'm like getting to the point
where I've got some stuff figured out. Okay. Life is coming together
and Uhhuh. All right. It's gonna happen. It's happening. It's
all happening. Everything's Everything's going to be awesome.
Okay, so patreon.com/jy.
Okay, hop on the Patreon, guys. Okay, any tier, espec especially
the $5 tier because if you sign up for the $5 tier, okay, if
you sign up for the $5 tier, you get image perms in the general
chat outside of streaming hours. Isn't that cool? Isn't that
so so so cool?
I think that's awesome. Anyway, yeah, thank you for asking me
to shield the Patreon, Meowies. You're welcome. Thank you. You're
welcome. I'm glad that you support so fervently. Thank you so
much.
Yep. Yep. Yep. I received a copyright uh I'm slightly out of
order here. There's lyrics, Twitter post, and then uh there's
Thor's copyright strike was supposed to be before this. I received
a copyright takedown and strike to my YouTube channel on Monday,
April 1st, 2019. So, copyright strike uh copyright strike Thor's
public portrayal. In response to my Twitter post, Thor would
claim that his strike was to prevent me, a scammer, from profiting
off of his work. As someone scamming us out of our income, I
would fight you into the ground to prevent you from making a
single cent off of our work. Thor employs an Well,
okay. He's like a piece of [__] or whatever. Okay,
he's going to play backpack battles and Oh my god, Cherry just
reminded me backpack battles went 1.0 today. Let's go. Oh my
god, you guys have to Oh, I can't. Hold on. We got to finish
this content first. But backpack battles went 1.0 today and it's
awesome. There's two new classes.
There's two new classes. This actually would be the perfect day
for a for a 24-hour stream. It actually would be the perfect
day cuz Backpack Battles is 1.0. I'mma play the [__]
out of that stuff. Okay,
that's awesome. Bro blew out his mic. Yeah. Yeah, cuz Backpack
Battles is
He's jumping on that yoga ball, guys. In excitement.
Uhhuh. That's the visual. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Bouncing up
and down. Thor employs an us versus them narrative where you
Oh, I was just going to say they did kind of scam.
Like the $800 was a donation. I believe it was for furry ERP
and you got the furry ERP.
You literally got the product you paid for. So, it is kind of
a scam. That's not wrong. Thor employs an us versus them narrative
where he portrays himself as the victim of a scammer and me as
a villain who's trying to profit off of his work. Thor's small
good guy lyric big bad guy. While his narrative would prove to
be very effective, the premise that I even make money off of
any of his work was unfounded. While it tends to be broadly accepted
that YouTubers make money off of videos, I turned off monetization
on my videos related to Heartbound by his own request. Videos
not monetized. Thor Thor reached out to me 24 hours after I published
my first Heartbound video.
Uh, great cover, but unfortunately you monetize the video, which
is against our content guidelines. Please refer to the frequently
asked questions regarding commercial use of our content. Please
either contact us for a license or remove advertisements on the
video. Aside from no, aside from this, nothing in the video description
leads anyone to our game or company. Please add crediting to
things like this to avoid users thinking that you are the original
creator. I'll check back in 24 hours to see if updates have been
made.
I've added a more descriptive
description to the video. I also removed ads for the video until
we can come to a licensing agreement.
Thor's email to Lyric. Uh, hold on here. I think this one. Okay.
Would it be okay to discuss the terms of the license here or
would you like me to contact the plus licensing email address?
Uh, hey there. Definitely hit us up at go pirate software
So, we'll be go So, we'll go through the proper filters. Thanks
for modifying the video. Thor. Oh, he's not they're not it's
not even Thor talking. Uh, hello. Still no news from YouTube
yet, unfortunately. Still waiting on their sport team to respond.
Thanks. Oh, sorry. That's response to this. Oh,
hey. Uh, any news on this yet? Would it be okay to publish another
one with proper credits and no monetization yet? Okay. We never
reached a licensing agreement. After I followed up on my request
for a license, I would give Thor advice on YouTube CMS system.
In a screenshot, I sent to Thor in our Discord DMs, showing him
content usage policy. It shows that I had monetization turned
off.
Okay. Thor's free publicity. Despite the fact that he did not
permit my videos to be monetized, Thor would encourage me to
make more content with his music. Hey Thor, should I Oh, whoops.
Hey, Thor, should I do every heartb heart sound?
Dude,
yes. Following this, I would arrange at least 20 songs for Heartbound
for Thor, though only three were published due to my release
schedule. I believe wanting more content is generally a normal
thing for a game developer to want. However, it should be noted
that Thor went out of his way to ensure that I was not monetizing
my videos while encouraging me to make more content for him,
which is essentially free free publicity for him. This is all
while he places financial pressures on me to donate to his projects
like this, like his Kickstarter. And after he got the free publicity,
he would weaponize my content by submitting a copyright strike
against my channel while publicly claiming that I was scamming
him.
Public perception.
I posted this that screenshot on Twitter and it would later contribute
to Thor's defense where I was painted as a scammer who premeditated
this ordeal. Um, replying to Pirate Software and Lyric Wolf.
I also love how their screenshot shows a time stamp of today.
Obviously, not in the current context of today's today. As if
this was all premeditated in some fashion that they knew they
were going to cause trouble and needed a defense. In reality,
the screenshot was taken today because I took the screenshot
to make a community post which I screenshotted to show Thor.
Oh,
Well, oh, well.
Oh, sorry. Yeah, that's awkward now. That's awkward now.
It's a Why is they Why are they woofing when they've got a Tails
picture? Tails is a fox.
Tails is a fox, guys. What are we doing? How do we not know that?
Okay. Thor's free publicity. We're good with that. So, that was
the copyright strike. We did Twitter post lyrics. Google Doc.
Oh god, I don't know if I can do the whole Google Doc. Where's
the Google Doc at? Oh, it's been Thank God it's been
Uh, on April 5th, 2019 at around 1:11 p.m., I published the doc,
A Great Heartbound Adventure, now deleted. At this time, I do
not have I do not have a copy of the original document, but we
see portions of the contents in the comments. Original URL for
a great heartbound adventure. No demiurge. No. No. No.
Analyzing the dock. The public comments reveal two statements
that I made in the original document. The reason that Thor and
I currently have an issue Oh, sorry. This is you. This is you.
This is you. Oh. The reason that Thor and I currently have an
issue with each other is due to our interaction at TwitchCon.
Leading up to this encounter, Thor and I shared many intimate
relations through our Telegram chat. Oh, this person has a really
big channel. 212K subs.
Um, they stopped making content, but they were absolutely making
like big videos at this time. They were ab dude, they're a furry
piano arrangement channel. They're doing furry related piano
arrangements from games and stuff.
That's crazy.
That's crazy. Oh, anyway, sorry, I got entranced by the music.
Cool stuff.
Okay, back to this.
Okay, it is apparent to me now that I focused on the wrong 212K
subs on that channel, by the way, and the video I clicked on
350,000 views. That's crazy. That's wild stuff. It is apparent
to me now I focused on the wrong details. At that time, I was
hurt and wasn't emotionally mature enough to fully comprehend
why, let alone put into words. Uh, I realized now that the emotional
manipulation I experienced was far more important to share. Yet,
I focused the details about his wife and about Sheay, which were
only at the forefront of my mind since that is when I felt I
was hurt. Due to that, I didn't read the chat logs, and I published
them in an attempt to explain what made me feel the way I did.
Looking back, the most important details are the interactions
before TwitchCon, how my vulnerabilities were exploited by someone
much older, and how I was manipulated into uh to devote myself
to entirely to Thor. All of the important information was reduced
simply to the statement, "Thor and I shared many intimate relations
through our Telegram chat. feedback. The initial feedback I received
after publishing the doc was almost entirely trolling at that
time. I believe that leaving the doc open to public comments
would help uh would help gauge what parts were unclear and refine
the document over time. However, I understand now that that was
not a good approach for multiple reasons. It nearly it yeah no
it nearly guarantees that the initial document will not be in
a ready state since there is less incentive for me to refine
the document before publication. There will necessarily be more
lowquality feedback than highquality. The reasoning behind this
is twofold. There are very few people who have both the time
who have the time to both read the document and formulate feedback.
A public forum and second, a public forum does not put us on
equal footing considering the imbalance of community activity
due to his large following. It is also it is a lose-lose situation
for fans to actually read the document since they have to spend
the time and energy to read it. There will necessarily be more
people interested in defending him by any means than those who
want to re-engage in reading a document which defames their idol.
It is not respectful of other people's time or of people's time.
It is not your job as a reader to proofread my document and suggest
improvements. Rather, it is my job to ensure I'm communicating
everything effectively, especially when I'm making accusations
against the other person.
Uh, addressing feedback.
I would like to address the only constructive comment I was able
to find. Anonymous comment. The images in the export were last
edited in 2018. You [__] liar.
The export uses Telegram's export chat history feature. All of
the files are generated at the time of export, including copies
of all stickers, media, and files. So, the creation date and
last modified date will both will both reflect the time of export.
Additionally, the entire archive does take place in 2018 between
the months of August and October. All feedback received. After
I published the document, Thor's community flooded the comments.
The coherent ones are listed below. Matt, do you want to read
a couple? Sure. Big stupid. Big stupid. What is this very
Uh,
what the I my game is PP
like small PP. I don't even know. Hold on. Hold on. Somebody
clip that. Send it to Wolf Gang. Somebody clip that. Send it
to Wolf Gang. Okay. Right now. I'm pretty sure I've heard you
call him Wolfie Boy in that voice. I think I've heard it. I'm
pretty sure I've heard that verbatim. I think just called him
Wolfie Boy in that voice right there. I've definitely gone like
and he gets bit
you're a good boy.
Yeah.
Yeah. Something like that.
Rick roll asy art. I don't even know what this is. Epic
in response to Thor abusing lyric. Who cares? He's a liar. Kill
him. Lol. I bet he likes his feet. Oh, sure. Go ahead. No, go
ahead.
He's a
Lol. I bet he likes his feet licked.
Okay. He He wants these
are all terrible. I want you to read I I actually want you to
read the rest of these.
Please, please do. Please do. This is so bad. Okay. Wolf blood.
G
Wolfy likes. He wants the duck and a little comic sense lyric.
We're gonna have bad time. Want some sack with fine? [__]
you. Time for BP. This is so This is a pirate softwares community.
Their best and brightest leaving comments on this document. Apparently
the comments were retrieved from email notifications.
Uh they've got email notifications going on here. Based cool.
Very cool. Very cool. Bold font. He wants the Thor, dude.
Okay. All right. Thor's
proxy
I would be convinced to delete all posts regarding this situation
through Thor and Shay's manipulation of my partner. Sheay lies
to my partner. On April 7th, my partner at the time contacted
Shay through a mutual friend.
Uh Sheay, he has been attacking us daily on Twitter. As for the
attack messages, he's been posting them as recently as yesterday.
So, I hope your conversations with him with him will get him
to stop. As part of his attack messages, he posted numerous chat
logs, some of which were modified and contained our lead developers
personal phone number/c contact info. The claims he's making
have led to his community attacking us over Thor's personal phone
number. Oh, they accidentally doxed Thor. That's not great. Oops.
I like how he said, "Here are the comments that were coherent,
and they were barely coherent." Yes. Yes. Pirates offer best
and brightest. All
From 2018. I think he's a pretty small channel in 2018 to be
fair.
Upon reviewing the archive, no sensitive information about Thor,
nor his phone number ever existed in any messages, media code,
or metadata of this archive. Even though it would be trivally
easy to disprove, this liot was told with such confidence that
there was no thought to verify it. Oh, you're as for Shea's claim
that the messages were modified, the Telegram archive has remained
unchanged since its archival date in December 2018.
Based on the claim that they were attacked over Thor's personal
phone number along with the knowledge that Thor's personal phone
number was never leaked, we can come to the this conclusion.
These are blatant lies not founded in truth. That's what a lie
is. Uh note that Sheay uses the word attack in all of their first
three messages. The repet the repetition of the word attack intends
to evoke a sense of urgency and danger and to paint Lyric as
a villain. This conversation led to my partner led my partner
to sympathize with Shay. I can't forgive the fact that he basically
docks you guys and that's a big yikes.
Uh, that's what the partner says.
Uh, Lyric can fix this on his end by deleting the post and reversing
the charge back. Get us our money back. Get us our money back
and maybe we'll talk about being cool. Okay,
maybe we'll talk about it. My partner tries to convince me. On
April 10th, my partner did as they promised to Shay. They tried
to convince me to reverse the chargeback and delete all public
posts about Thor. I expressed my distrust in them and discussed
at how they are twisting the situation. My partner empathized
with Sheay, trying to get me to consider that I might be at fault
for misunderstanding the situation and that I should stop harassing
them. At this at that time or at that point in time
at that point in time, I was not at all interested in deleting
posts or my posts because I felt I was in the right and I would
keep fighting them to make it known because I have the proof.
On April 13th, my partner informed me, "Sheay/Tor are calling
restraining order. I can't just let them call the lawyer on you."
I expressed that I heavily distrust them. I pointed out that
they are asking me to delete their delete for their own gain,
so it would look like I deleted my post because I regretted posting
them. Subtle foreshadowing
here. Go ahead if you want to read this part. Meowies. Okay.
I noticed how my tone shifted over from not wanting to delete
it at all to wanting to mutually end the drama. I was motivated
by having a happy life with my partner at the time, free of any
past burdens. Looking back on this, I do regret not standing
my ground. I did not have any have a good sense of boundaries
at the age. If my partner told me to do something, I would try
to find a way, even giving up my own goals. And in this instance,
my own emotional well-being. I realize now that this was not
a virtue.
Two seconds. I took a bite of my sandwich when I was when you
were reading. Oh, good. Why doesn't Thor just transfer money
to PayPal to cover the negative balance? I don't think Thor was
making very much money at this point. 2019, I think he was really
small. I think this person was probably like a significant amount
of his income at some point. Yeah. Well, yeah. I'm not the aggressor
here. If he calls off the attack, all this goes away pretty fast.
This is the partner, but you go for it, Maries. All right. Um
All right. Just to be sure, if he deletes every single Oh my,
what is this English? Jesus Christ. Um All right. Just to make
sure if he deletes every single thing from Twitter, Discord,
and everything on YouTube community, will you do the following
same thing? Uh, Thor's confirmation.
he's dragging it out so hard.
Um, this will be them, I think.
I don't know why. Wait, is this not Thor's confirmation?
Yeah, I'm not the aggressor here. If he calls off the attack.
Okay. All right. Yeah. Okay. No, it's at the bottom that we read.
All right. I took them at their word.
It is clear to me now that in this type of situation, I should
know that deleting my post in the situation is a terrible idea.
Even without outside perspective, I should know that they are
not trustworthy. They are manipulating my partner for the goal
of manipulating me. I lend myself to believe that their narrative
uh to believe their narrative to some extent. I never even checked
if there was actually personal information leaked. Since I did
not review any of the contents of the archive before posting
it, uh that's not good to begin with. But after I read Thor's
confirmation, I deleted all of my posts on all platforms, including
the Google doc I wrote.
At this time, neither Sheay nor Thor deleted their posts on the
matter until years later. All of their posts on Twitter, Discord,
and YouTube were made public, and they would continue to call
me a scammer and a liar long after I deleted my posts. This would
confirm the foreshadowing I mentioned earlier. They manipulated
my partner to get me to delete my posts, and then they would
keep their posts up, reinforcing their narrative and painting
me as a villain. At this time, I do not have original copies
of my deleted posts. Transcripts: Conversations between Shay,
my partner, forwarded to me by my partner. Conversations between
lyric and partner screenshot taken by me at the time. I'm good.
So Thor's defense effects on my life. A sides effects on my life.
Um I think I'm about to jump over to
Oh, they like quit YouTube. Okay. Well, no, we might as well.
For the sake of completeness, we're gonna finish the whole thing.
Okay. Make me read. Okay. Meowis can do all of the Darvo section.
Let's examine how Thor defended himself against the claims made
in my document. The statements below are Thor's claims which
can be deduced because they are not speculation and are be or
because they are claimed by Sheay. For example, it is most likely
speculation to say you must have planned this because of this
information. However, it is definitely not speculation to say
Thor is divorced. This information cannot be produced by speculation
and would only stem from claims made by Thor towards his community.
I'm reading this. Yeah, this be the Darvo section right here.
Uh, Darvo, which stands for deny, attack, and reverse victim
and offender, is a manipulative tactic used by abusers to detect
blame or deflect blame and shift the narrative. Thor's defense
is a textbook example of Darvo. In this case, Thor employed Darvo
to deny allegations uh made against him, claiming that he is
not even married. Um, except he wait, is this like
the oo voice that I should do here, or am I just like helping
you read because you want to eat your sandwich?
Uh, this is me you helping me read. Okay. I'm not eating my sandwich,
but I was you helping me read. Okay. People say they want the
voice though anyway. Oh, you do the voice conduct. H, you sick.
Oh, you know, I'll just read this all in the voice. You worse.
Except he does it and never did. Thor and I weren't together
and him and his wife were divorced.
Attack Lyric by accusing them, planning the entire situation,
and directly communicating with Lyric's partner to attack their
character.
uh quote, "He was very h happily
interacting with us and chat and soaking up praise for donating
so much. He continued to visit stream every day and talk with
us afterwards." End quote. Reverse victim and offender by portraying
himself as the victim of lyrics attacks. Quote, "They are a small
indie studio that Lyric scam. They are under attack because Lyric
docks them." End quote.
uh charging back after giving it into a small indie studio scamming
us out of our income. As part of his attack messages, he posted
numerous chat logs, some of which were modified and contained
our lead developer's personal phone number.
So, uh they're lying and the original person was lying. I think
the original person charging it back was probably pretty bad
and just like kind of petty. Yeah, but it's it's petty on both
sides. I don't know if this is quite Darvo to be honest because
this is like not you you kind of were like the offender in the
situation where he charged back but whatever whatever
Thor is divorced. Thor was married to his wife Nicole Gillette
from October 2015 to February 2020. We also know that they were
living together until February 2019 which is before TwitchCon
in October of 2018. Source: Thor's marriage. Oh, what a crazy
source. Jason Thorhal was married to Nicole Gillette from October
17th, 2015 to October or August 19th, 2020. Jason Thorhal marries
Nicole Gillette. Jason Nicole no longer live in the same house.
February in 2019. February 18th, 2020, Jason and Nicole filed
for divorce at the Lamo Justice Center in Orange County, California.
The court assigns case number two uh 2000
01318.
Divorce marriage dissolved after mandatory 6-month cooling off
period. Public records for marriage and divorce, which we're
not going to read through. Crazy. Oh, what's up, Wubby? How's
it going, buddy?
Thor is divorced. Only Ferrets River makes except he doesn't
never did. Thor and I weren't together with him and his uh weren't
together and him and his wife were divorced. I think this must
be Shay, right?
At River Makes.
I think this is Sheay only ferrets. This is Shay. Shay 29. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Thor and I weren't
together and him and his wife are divorced. You tried to push
yourself on him and onto me and then onto me when he rejected
you. Did you forget all the time you spent on my arm at TwitchCon?
from what I've gathered, you've totally made up the part about
him sleeping with you and his wife at the same time because he
is not with his wife. So, GG on that one. Additionally, regretting
a relationship and interactions after the fact does not mean
he used you.
Uh, I don't think they're romantic either, considering they're
divorced, but I
uh they were not divorced at this point. They were possibly not
living together in the same house at this point in February of
2019.
Lyric doc storeed messages. The Telegram chat logs remaining
entirely unchanged since it's archival date in December 2018
never contain any personal information except for L's phone number
occurring twice. See Telegram archive. I agree. But Lyric released
Telegram chat logs which included Thor's real personal phone
number. So he's essentially gotten doxed and people who have
already started people have already started subscribing him to
with his number.
uh statements made to my partner and my partner in Thor's proxy
by black Thor's proxy blackmail as part of his attack messages.
He posted our number. Yeah. Blah blah blah.
Mr. Context.
What?
Could I have the full story with the chargeback/donation thing?
It's right here. I think I I posted it in the thread, but here
it is. Okay. Uh well, wait. So, this happened recently. Technically,
you're doxing him, and generally this will just hurt you in the
end with that.
by accident to be honest. I think his phone number is there.
I just uploaded it as is because I didn't want any editing or
doctoring of the messages. I think my number is in there as well.
Okay, thanks. I think it's better to hear both sides of the story.
Uh Lyric also states here, I just uploaded it as uh because I
didn't want editing or whatever. Sure.
Lyric planned this and he is a scammer. Thor would tell Lyric
about donation opportunities, then would withhold attention until
L donated, for example, in his Kickstarter. Money would also
be one of Thor's primary goals. Okay, simple flips. Just because
someone else was a doesn't change what I said. You're still you're
still someone who charged back an $800 donation. I see very little
difference between what you did and what some creepy dude does
to a female streamer. Uh when a female streamer bans them and
they start charging back donations.
Uh kind of.
I don't know why you made it like Oh, I don't know why that needed
to be It's Yeah, it's the same. Do more people empathize with
this? What? Who's your like follow base where you're like, "Yeah,
it's like when a S charges back." Well, how would that help?
It's the exact same thing. Exact same behavior. How is that making
it clearer for you? Oh, I get it. It's more like the um like,
"Oh, there are a bunch of simps." It's like when when somebody's
like assaulted and people are like, "Imagine that happened to
your sister." Right? Imagine that happened to your sister, your
mom. Wouldn't you be mad trying to teach somebody to have empathy?
Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. When the donation was made, he
very he was very happily interacting with us and chat and soaking
uh uh and chat and soaking up praise for donating so much. He
continued to visit the stream every day and talk with with us
afterwards with the amount being listed at the ticker at the
top of the screen, but also on the bit boss.
Uh I also love how their screenshot shows a time stamp of today.
Uh we saw this already.
Uh why even screen cap the day of interaction? So basically because
they screen capped like day of stuff, they were saying, "Oh,
well it's obviously like weeks ago, but you screen capped the
day of cuz you knew you knew you'd need a defense later." It
was kind of goofy. Uh, this is my face when reading it. Like
how do you come up with this stuff? Do you want to just throw
this one out? Yeah, it's physically painful. Who has this much
time? These guys are in a furry streamers discord and they're
talking about who has enough time to do things. Crazy.
Okay. Do you want to start this one? You could read down to here.
Whatever.
Hold on. I do try to keep myself from feeling and speaking like
a victim, but right now it really feels like that's what I am,
a victim. I truly wish I was never a part of this. I have never
ever wanted to blame that situation for how my life turned out.
I never wanted to think anything like that because I want to
believe that I'm in control of my own life, but I also can't
deny the facts.
career. I was in college during these events, completing my undergraduate
requirements and double majoring in mechanical engineering and
aerospace engineering. Why do like furries they're always in
this like field? It's so strange that in the military I don't
I don't understand. Uh yeah, I really don't know. I don't know
what it is. Uh here are transcripts from the semester before
the events happened. I maintained a GPA of Wait, hold on. Wait,
what? This is not what they usually do. They usually do programming,
right? What do you mean mechanical engineering and aerospace?
Well, just like STEM, STEM. Sure. STEM generalization. Yeah.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Okay. Um, I maintained a GPA of 3.92.
I received the deans list and the president's honor role accolades
from every semester.
After the events midfall 2018, my academic performance plummeted.
I finished the fall 2018 semester with a
GPA and was stripped of my honors accolades. The following semester,
I finished with a 2.75
GPA. Okay. Uh, okay. Okay. Yeah, I know. Keep going. Yeah, you
might as well keep going. I can start a YouTube. After that semester,
I dropped out of college. Growing up, I was always the gifted
kid, the one with a bright future. I was able to maintain a 3.9
GPA, taking every summer semester, too, all while maintaining
my content creation. I didn't think it affected me then. I always
thought it was my own decision. I believed that I dropped out
because I just couldn't handle the pressure. That a life where
I make the next big thing to improve my humanity was never in
reach for me to begin with. I thought I just wasn't smart enough.
After reviewing my transcripts, I can see they tell a different
story entirely. YouTube, here's a table of my YouTube and live
stream counts. From here, just called posts.
2016 173 2017 156 2018 192
2019 99 2020 26 2021 1 2022 1 2023 zero 2024 zero
In June 2019 I dropped out of college I had much more time to
work on creating content yet my productivity plummeted in April
2019 when I tried to speak out Thor turned everyone against me
destroyed my perception of the online community after his lies
were taken his truth like academics I thought always thought
I stopped being motivated to content because that that life just
wasn't meant for me. I thought I was creatively burnt out. I
felt like I had peaked that I had already created everything
good that I will ever make. I thought I just wasn't creative
enough.
Wow. That's like the end, by the way. That's like the end of
her entire post, which is crazy.
Okay, we've got two more posts here. We've got Pirate Software's
response and then their response to Pirate Software's response.
Okay,
this is Pirate Software posted a response here
which goes pretty hard. Okay, so this is the first post from
Lyric from Lyric Wolf. Pirate Software responds after 5 years
you've come back around to try to push I try pushing this LAR
again because I'm a big creator now. It didn't work in 2020 because
everyone called you on your and it's not going to work now. You
were a massive donator to our game in the very beginning and
tried to use that to get close to both Rivermakes and I and myself.
It worked and we were good friends for a bit there. When you
were in that sphere of friendship, you tried to push that to
something and I turned you down. Oh, he's just totally lying.
He's just completely lying.
Okay. And I turned you down. After that, you went after Shay
and made her so uncomfortable that she panics when thinking about
that convention center to this day and doesn't want to go to
conventions anymore. Then you charge back all your donations
and tried to [__] our studio. She charged back one
donation, actually, not all of them. Uh, so another lie, just
lying again. Blatantly lying. This guy's lying
again. Your own boyfriend at the time warned us with how toxic
and dangerous you were. Dude wasn't wrong. You've spent the last
four months working on on this hit piece website as shown in
your GitHub and the last 5 years trying to form the perfect argument
to take me down before you edited our logs and made them some
weird cartoon of who I am. Hell, your own website has you talking
in the third person and typing as if you're speaking from my
perspective all over it. This is unhinged and pathetic. You're
a parasitic piece of [__] and you need to leave us
the alone. See you at 2030 when you inevitably try this [__]
again. Uh, now I want to see your your own boyfriend at the time
warned us how toxic and dangerous you were. I now I want to see
where that is cuz I feel like we that was probably in the logs
we skipped. That was in um what? Thor's proxy blackmail. There
was like I think so.
Uh
Shane partner Shay forwarded messages. Shane partner.
Uh I hope so too.
So I hope so too. but it uh but have been putting you guys into
a very bad bad spot and that is not okay at all. To be fair to
these kinds of stuff on PayPal, it's going to be very hard. Though
I honestly really want you guys to get it resolved because this
is very bad timing considering that you guys are moving at the
moment. I can try to find a way to convince him to repeal the
case and return you the money, but I'm unsure if he will or not.
I can't tell you. I can't tell, but I really want to help with
this because no content creators deserve this.
You want to grab Sha's end here real quick? Sure. Uh thank you.
That's really nice to hear. While I can't ask you to do something
like that, if you do end up talking to him about it, it would
mean a lot to us.
And for this, I feel like there was some misunderstanding from
his side because someone told him Thor having a wife and he told
me he just went mad about it and apparently he didn't think twice.
I think he was very extremely clingy and was thought he's in
a relationship. I presume this person is English. This person
is gig at ESL. But but also I did know a little bit about it
and to me if I felt like it wasn't right from the start until
now you gave me about this details.
Uh I also I know a little bit about the info on his Twitter and
I can't forgive the fact that he basically docks you guys and
that's a big yikes. I'm sorry that you have to deal with this.
This is why I have to step up and get in contact with you because
this is uh about this because like I said I want to get it all
clear, fair and square to you both. Also I will see what I can
do with that.
Again, thank you very much. If there's anything you ever need
from either of us, please just let me know.
No problem at all. But yeah, I think I just need to ask two more
things. And it is okay/ possible for him to talk to you guys.
He told me he is very sorry. He very sorry. So he told me he
very sorry about it and he want to resolve on his own, not me.
Wow. So true.
Uh whoops. This is the last one. source of forwarded messages
boarded from
Is there anywhere I can donate to you both?
So extremely clingy.
Oh, those are the actual screenshots from the Yeah, those are
the actual screenshots. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm trying to find where
he says like, "Oh, this person's like unhinged, I guess. Extremely
clingy. Your boyfriend warned us how toxic and dangerous you
were." I don't think the boyfriend did that. It was like, "Hey,
they're like clingy, but I'll step up and like make this right."
And that was based on false information based on them thinking
that the the the
lyric wolf person doxed Thor, which he didn't. Yeah, Thor should.
Sorry, I'm going to read some of the comments. Thor should drop
a defamation lawsuit on her him. But I dare them. We'd have to
prove the allegations are false. So realistically, that will
never happen.
You know you just got doxed on Reddit for this, right? Bullying
won't work this time. It's the other way around. You know, you
just got doxed on. Dude, this person's psychotic, bro. What the
is this?
This person's like, "Hey,
um,
you know, you know you're getting doxed for this, right? I don't
have a dog in this fight." Just saying. Uh, this person is a
total
This person's an
This person's disgusting.
You know, you just got docked for this, right? You really want
to pursue this, you dumb. You stupid.
God, why is this behavior so prevalent on Twi on Twitter? Why
are people like this
happening? Uh,
bizarre. Bizarre. I will no longer free school this person's
Twitter. That's
Effective accelerationist. Yeah, sure. This person's already
in the in the bio. Don't have to take this guy seriously at all.
All right.
Anyway, the lyric wolf stuff is crazy. Now, I believe Lyricwolf
does their own response to Thor's response. Let's check it out.
Maybe they pick it apart and show exactly where he's lying.
Pirate Software and Sheay lied in their response. I know a lot
of you have talked about this as a nothing burger, but this right
here proves that Thor and Shay are lying to you in their
Oh god, it's more
It's actually It's
this time. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no.
But it looks like Pirate Software deleted his uh his side.
So these are Discord messages. Is this meant to show you that?
Okay, hold on. So here, we'll we'll read their next thing. Despite
deleting all of your messages, Pirate Software, you cannot delete
the history of calls that we shared together after my erotic
roleplay messages. Despite you claiming to end our relationship
after rejecting my advances, that's why you even called me yourself,
right, Thor?
Yeah, it's a little weird that Thor would call back to them.
Right. A little bit. Little bit. Little bit.
I'm just I'm just If Meowis wanted to, she could, but I'm not
pushing anybody to do this. Okay. It's a little much. This is
a little much. Yeah, it's a little much. Silly Oo.
Okay.
When you were in this sphere of a of a friendship, you tried
to push something. Uh that something I turned you down. Yeah,
that definitely just didn't happen. That's just a flatout lie
from big old pirate software there. Flatout lie.
Your HTML chat logs rehashed it into Oh, you your HTML chat logs
rehashed into a neat little package with a pretty little bow
on top and the extra added flare that reads to anyone with more
than a speck of higher Oh,
hold on. Wait, did he edit his post? He edited his post, didn't
he? Is this
Maybe not. Wait, wait, where are there multiple posts or something?
Cuz this is like different, isn't it? Oh, this is River. Oh,
that's why. Yeah, that's from River. I didn't read the river
post yet. Do you know how weird it is to have an entire GitHub
repo for your allegations? Seething and boiling for who knows
how long before that going so far as to stock replies I made
to you 5 years ago when you first tried this and for what? You
claimed to have nothing to lose and a prosperous life outside
of the internet. But your dedication to this reeks of obsession
and desperation. You took the [__] You took the same
[__] you said in 2019. Your HTML chat logs, rehashed
it into a neat little package with a pretty little bow on top
and extra added flare text that reads to anyone with more than
a speck of higher thought like a one-sided lovesick fanfiction.
Actually, just reads like chatgpt analysis to the chat logs with
maybe some directing and pushing. Okay.
I would keep in mind that everyone who came forward about you
reaching out of uh of their own accord after reading your initial
post, including your boyfriend at the time, they were sympathetic
to us because that wasn't the first time you had acted this way.
You are a delusional, manipulative, pathological liar that worms
his way into people's lives. And it's sickening. Speaking from
my perspective all over it, this is unhinged and pathetic. You're
a parasitic piece of [__] and you need to leave us
the alone. See you in 2030 when you inevitably try this again.
They end with the same thing. You're parasitic piece of [__]
and you need to leave us the alone. See you in 2030 when you
inevitably try this [__] again.
They're already software.
Who? This like sh person. They were already dating when this
TwitchCon stuff happened. Yes. Yep. Okay. I figured it out. Okay.
She What's up? Got cheated on by a gay furry boy. Okay. Realistically
speaking, and she can't handle it. So, she's now deluded herself
and she's in like some sort of like weird Dulu mind palace and
that's why she's being extra aggressive on this guy instead of
just understanding that she should have just dumped Thor back
in 2018 for being a hoe. Uh yeah, obviously.
So, so it's like it's I don't know. Like you're basically saying
that they rationalized defending him back then and they're probably
just like uh like totally minded. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Just they're
going to defend him no matter what now. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Many
such cases.
Okay. That's why you even That's why you even started these 10-hour
calls, right, Thor? Cuz you rejected me or cuz he rejected me,
right? Oh, you're so destroyed right now. But nobody's actually
signal boosting this dude. This person is totally decimating
Pirate Software. We have no signal boosting. Okay. Do I need
to call up somebody who's close to the ADL who has a lot of Twitter
poll who can start getting these things boosted? Cuz this person's
destroying Pirate Software and Pirate Nobody's seeing it. 19,000
views versus what is what is the initial post? 30 95,000. Pirate
Software [__] has a million views. This person needs
to get signal boosted.
9 hours in a call with somebody.
He started a call for 9 hours. Yeah. Yeah. This is weird. This
is weird. 9 hour calls, bro. 9 hour calls, bro.
13our calls, bro.
What the 13 hours? Yeah, that was a reference to Dan. Yeah, Dan
could uh Dan hates this guy. We just got to package this up correctly.
Dude, he's actually like around here. He's actually like destroyed
and it doesn't matter. Okay, this is unedited Discord footage,
by the way. That's your account, Pirate Software. It even has
the exact same date of creation. Shay, I guess despite you and
Thor being people with a speck of higher thought, you forgot
about how Discord logs your call history and who started it.
Uh-huh.
We don't have receipts because he nuked all of his chats
when Thor's messages are the ones that are deleted. I guess a
normal convo for you is spending 10 hours in a voice call with
someone you supposedly turned down because of weird behavior.
The problem is that destroying
It's over. Might be one of those. No, it's not one of those situations
cuz it's happening repeatedly after behavior that he says pirate
software says made him reject this person. No, it's happening
over and over and over again after the conversations. Anyway,
we uh so the problem is that he knows we don't have receipts
because he nuked all of his chats before he tried this originally.
So, we couldn't save anything. It was heavily planned. Not like
there was anything but like normal combo/combo but stream etc.
Dude, these people just lie all over the place. This is another
lie. There's more lies. There's insane lies, dude. The fair have
to be stopped. Okay, the fair got to go down at any cost. This
is crazy.
They just lied about this person and this person's like a weirdo.
Okay, but they totally lied and made up everything about this
person. They're just They're just lying again.
This is crazy. I don't care what you think of me, but what you
see here is Thor's repetitive, dishonest behavior. The same thing
he did to Ross Scott and S and uh stop games. The same thing
he did to Yumato and WoW. The same thing he did to Eve Online
devs. And the same thing he did to Mr. robots, creators, etc.
It's the same dishonesty he had in 2019 when he accused me of
doxing him despite his number never existing in the chat logs
when running a phone number search uh search using reax. The
same chat log that has remained unchanged since I first posted
it in 2018.
It's the same dishonesty he expressed. Sorry, we should look
through this. So, there's somebody who says we saw that log in
the in the website. This is River's accusation of doxing.
This is
logs. Is this first publication time of export? Okay. Exported
from Telegram desktop December 18th. If this if you could verify
the check sums from before,
that'd be very interesting. So you couldn't find his number anywhere
in it. Interesting.
A global search of the archive for phone numbers only reveals
two instances of Lyric's phone number. So Lyric's phone number
is the only one there.
Okay. Um Oh, this is the Red Jack, isn't it? Uh it would match
the following examples and much more. Okay.
Okay.
Well, hold on. That's not saying it's not there. That's saying
this is how we searched and we didn't find it, which is a little
different. It's the same dishonesty he expressed about Heartbound.
So, the next time Thor and Shay say anything, remember their
track record before you accept their words. Thor and his team
have a history of deception and manipulation that intentionally
distorts the truth of the situation. Bro, this person's a loser.
This This person like actually won and nobody cares. That's crazy.
It sucks that the internet's like this to some extent that like
I don't want to be on Tommy C's page, but like we need to find
the right way to like go after Thor here. It's probably a YouTube
video of some kind because it's another situation where I thought
this was a nothing burger and they just didn't distill this down
well and they told this story really poorly. This story can be
told in a way that would totally with Thor, but that's not how
they told it, unfortunately. Yeah, Lyric's cringe, but L was
objectively like kind of over by this guy. Like Thor totally
was trying to get in a relationship with this person. And then
the second Thor like and then Thor was basically telling them
they got super jealous of this person being in any kind of remotely
relationship with another person while maintaining other relationships
themselves and totally guilting this person about it. Guilting
them into donating extra money. Guilting them after they pulled
back some of their money after they said they were going to credit
card debt to donate money. Okay. And then when when that person
gets to TwitchCon and and Thor is like making it clear that he's
cheating on his girlfriend or whatever the boyfriend, whatever
Shay is. Okay. And then this person shares the logs with Shay.
This person's the dishonest loser, scammer, whatever coming out
of this, right? How
Thor around the whole time.
What are these messages? People are currently review bombing
this. They're very upset. And I can understand why in some of
those cases I haven't worked on the game for the last year. When
will Harbound full release? I'm working on that. My hope is to
get out uh Animus very soon, within the next month. This is what
I work on when I'm not on stream 99% of the time. So, right now,
I'm actually in the middle of making this environment right here,
which is incredibly enormous, right? And these are the last two
environments that need to be done for Animus to be finished.
2025 release, we're actually planning on releasing it, almost
all of it this year, you know, cuz I only have this much left.
Animus is 98% completed, by the way. And then we have the final
scene for Animus and we're done. Animus is almost done, by the
way. When Animus is done,
I did think Thor is first. No, you're XXX10 trashman. You're
just totally wrong. You're just actually totally wrong. You're
like just brainless.
If you if you've watched all of this,
explain to me why Thor is why it's cool for Thor to totally guilt
this person out of any other relationship without saying, "Yeah,
but I'm maintaining relationships myself." Explain to me why
that's cool. And then explain to me why it's cool to go and just
lie about them completely in the response. just make up repeated
lies about it.
Why is that cool? Just give it a Oh, sure. Yeah. All of his times
where he says Thor Heartbound's coming out soon, guys. I promise.
Three months. Okay. This is This is basically me with Oiler Calls.
Okay. This is me and Oiler Calls right here
100%.
So, when we look at this, Animus is 98% complete and the overall
game is 89% completed. The Clash is super ready and that's kind
of what we're working on right now. Animus is at 99% completion.
That six months ago I was also really close to finishing Animus,
but then the community exploded in size and now I'm finally actually
close to finishing Animus
for real this time. I'm really glad the the next update should
finish up Animus, which I've finished the writing for finally.
Um, so I actually I just finished all the writing for Animus,
which is kind of cool. Animus is
basically textwise done and this is what needs to get done for
Animus to be done. These two rooms are all that's left. And I'm
wor I worked on all of this. The the writing is actually done
for these two. So I actually have to mark those out for ENUS.
So these are actually done with Heartbound. I've actually been
working on it off stream every day like I have been for months
and I'm done with most of the writing for the end of Animus.
Like it's basically done. How's your progress with Heartbound?
Great. I actually finished off a whole section for Animus that
I was really happy about the other day. How's Harbun's progress?
Harbin's doing really well. Still going by the way. Bunch of
like dialogue stuff for Animus last night. And basically, I'm
just working on the combat scene at the end of Animus now, which
is nice. It's like the last piece I need. Finally finished the
Grand. Animus is probably like a section of his game. Writing
needed for Animus and Heartbound. Yeah, Animus is basically finished.
I'm pretty happy with it now. How done is Animus? Animus is very,
very close to being I haven't worked on the game, dude. Is Animus
out now? Animus has to be out now, right?
Animus has to be out now. There's no way that Animus is not done.
Where is
Is it really not? Wait, is it really? Is Animus. It's not the
whole game. I don't think anything is done,
dude. There's no way. Animus has to be out now. Hold on. Animus
Heartbound.
Uh, okay.
Animus or act three has is one of three locations. Lore gets
transported uh after defeating the bag the bar guest and confronting
the artifact in the dark world or after completing the previous
location the player chose chooses. Uh Animus has an autominal
theme and has a functioning day and night cycle that goes for
24 minutes before looping. All the inhabitants of this world
are talking animals that have routines that'll keep the village
in balance.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Jesus.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Uh, I don't see this
being out. Wait, is this out? No, it's it's like not binders.
Clock home subloations.
Okay.
Is Animus finished?
Oh, Animus Exploration Heartbound 1.0.7D
Animus Exploration.
Animus new content.
The base in Oh, when was this? When was this? This was January
20, 2019. Wait, no, that's okay. Okay, that can't quite be right.
So, this has to be Yeah, he's talking about finishing Animus.
I see. I see.
So, it was unfinished or it's like released partially finished,
right? And it's not It's not actually finished or wasn't finished
at least in February 20 on February 21st, 2025.
Hold on.
I have to respond to chatter. Jinx. Okay. Talking animals. Who
would buy that crap? Have you ever heard of the game Animal Crossing?
That is pog. Okay. Animal Crossing
is fire. And there's talking animals. They talking animal. Okay.
They just say jibber jabber. I'll be right back. But Animal Crossing
is dope. Okay. Wait. And you get to build a house. Yes, I did.
I'm talking to chat.
I'm entertaining the
No, I'm not. No. No. No. Wait a minute. Hold on. Do not pur this
on me. Animal Crossing is cool. You don't have to be a furry.
Okay. Yes. Tom Nook gang. Actually, yes. Tom Nook is not the
villain. He is the protagonist of that entire game. Okay. You
He was so generous to give you a home. Okay. Without paying a
scent. He's like, "You're broke ass. Here's a full ass home.
Okay.
You get to pay him back. That is perfect. That's like the perfect
landlord.
Okay. Here's an entire house. Okay. and his kids run the shop.
Awesome.
He keeps it all in the family.
What a good dad. Tom Nook the sugar daddy. That's too far. Tom
Crook. You guys are haters. People who say Tom
I think you're probably broke IRL. I'm going to be honest.
Tom Crook. That's crazy. Oh, his nephews. My bad. My bad. Why
are you like this?
Technommancer. What the? All Tom Crooks are anti-Semitic. True.
Okay.
But Tom Nuck himself.
He's
You can't convince me otherwise. Okay. Is that the theme now
of this stream is having fat avatars? Does Jical have a fat avatar?
Commence the feeding. You are sick. Who is this drunk trying
to defend Tom Nook?
You are calling him Tom Crook. He is not Tom Crook. You are just
broke. You are probably broke IRL and in the game.
I bet your house looks like Get it together. Either Tom Crook
is a Zion. Dude, this is crazy.
We do not need to make Animal Crossing into an Israel Palestine
debate. That's insane. We are back. Hello.
Hello. Okay.
Um, let's see here. We got 4 minutes left. I need six subs for
another hour and maybe do uh Destiny Ox. I'm not totally sure.
I think we're basically done with this. Um,
or maybe I have content meowies would be interested in. Hold
on. What is there?
Uh, I don't think so. Actually,
I don't think I really have Meowi's
good time good meowies times content. I don't know. Oh, also
I said we should have a fat JTO, but I think um Top Bronson's
gone for a little bit. He out for a little while.
Go over M getting punched. I did that like a week ago when it
happened, didn't I? Like four days ago, 5 days ago when it happened.
I went over it on stream. You're just mad. I called you out.
Tent trash man. You're just mad I called you out. You are brokey
IRL and in Animal Crossing. Pay your house. Pay your rent. And
King Gedra I Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Nook is
based if that's the case. Darius punched her. No, she got punched
in the face by a protester at a what do you call it. Yeah, she
got punched in the face by a
Oh, I totally forgot. Also, we only have like 3 minutes left
in the stream. So there might not be any more content. Ding.
Might be a night for an oiler call. I wonder what I do in order.
Yeah. Is that because I called you out on it? No, cuz it usually
we go way way longer on stream, but if we're ending 5 hours in,
then I'm good. Go do an oil call. Possibly. Yeah.
You're welcome, chat.
well, if there's nothing else. Okay.
Money by Monday. Okay. Money by Monday or your toast.
There is no maybe. It's money by Monday. Maybe. Maybe. Maybe.
Are you Are you also saying you're broke? Can you still not afford
sliced
Uh, yeah. Obviously, we're very broke right now. Yeah, not really.
Um,
not really actually broke. Sad day. Not sure what I'm going to
do. What should we do at the call? I'm trying to think.
H uh backpack battles like Jerry said. Oh, I could go live and
just do like random stuff in backpack battles. But you could
I actually can go uh you know if we want to if we want to spend
some
Oh, apparently Murk was talking [__] about people
in Darius's house. Hold on. What did she say about Legacy over
here? No. Leave Legacy alone. Don't ever want to talk to him
again. Who else? Legacy. Legacy. I'm going to tell you what nobody
else is willing to tell you. You are a content reducer. Legacy,
people have scripts. People want
the script. I think basically everybody tells Legacy that all
the time. Actually,
does anybody not tell Legacy that that you're a content reducer?
Like pretty much everybody is like, "Legacy, you stop telling
us to be responsible."
People want to create content. You are reducing that. And the
only reason that they're putting up with it, I don't know why
Mark has a feet cam on. Okay. Do you think that any of these
people have the credit to rent a house? Do you think any of these
people have the ability to rent a house? We all have heard it.
You like to brag. You're a you're a what is it? A trust fund
baby. You're you're you're a trust fund baby. You have all the
money. You've bragged. You know you're a trust fund baby. Okay,
cool. Is he really a trust fund baby? Everyone knows that the
only reason they keep you around is because you
going to get a nice inheritance. Uh where's the where are the
donations? My question. Where are the donations? What's happening?
Legacy, what the dude? Legacy, what the you are the one who is
the least. Talk about legacy. You're the one who who has the
house and everyone is willing to put up with your [__]
because of the house. If they didn't have that, nobody would
want to be around you. They don't they don't like you, okay?
They they think you're a content producer. You ruin scripts.
You ruin you ruin memes. You you ruin trolls. You need to let
people do what they need to do and move on. And and you get a
little bit of alcohol in your system and you act crazy. And you
know what? It takes one to no one. Exactly. You're right. You're
right. You're right. and you have a problem with me because apparently
um I owe you $30, but then you told me the other day that it
was a script and that I don't actually owe you money money and
that you actually really like me and that you actually think
I'm funny and that that I'm that you're my friend and I sit there
and cry to you about Darius to your face and you're like like
I love you. Everyone in the house loves you like you're Bro,
why is Legacy taking all these women letting them cry on his
shoulder? What are you doing Legacy? What is this your Riz bro?
You find the girls that cry and then you're like, "Hey, do you
want to come cry next to me?" Legacy, what are you doing? It's
not. You see it, don't you, Maddies?
No, he's gay. No, he's not. No, he's not. He's He is not gay.
He's bisexual. He is gay.
No. Oh, he's not. He is so gay until he gets these women to feel
vulnerable. Okay. until somebody makes these women feel vulnerable
and they start crying to Legacy and then he has a couple drinks
and he's like, "Oh, when I'm when I'm drunk, I'm by."
Wow. Wow.
Incredible.
Incredible. I see you, Legacy. I see you. Meowi sees you. Meow's
absolutely sees you. Everybody sees you, bro.
Everybody sees you, bro. Everybody sees
Uh, okay. Hold on. We continue. There's one more. There's one
more clip from plant dad. Actually, these are your clips. Plant
dad back and talk so much about me. You're an alcoholic and you're
being used. Surprise. It happens to people like us. We get used.
Okay. But don't think for a second that they actually enjoy having
you around because you're a content.
Legacy, you're just like Mk off the perk. Legacy, you and Mk
are basically the same person. Did you see the merc rebound already?
I just got back to the stream. Nope. Didn't see it. Don't know
what you're talking about. Sir, next person squeeze. Next person.
Squeeze. Okay. She talks about a bunch of the roommates, apparently.
Hold on. Good luck, buddy. That's all I'm gonna say. Squeeze.
Um, there it is. I have nothing negative to say about you. Good
luck, buddy. That's all I'm going to say. Um, Prawn. Um,
guess what, Prawn? Darius doesn't actually like Oh, come on.
You're going to go after Prawn right now, guys. One sub away
from another hour on the stream. Okay. One hour. One sub away
from another hour on the stream. me and you had a talk about
you too. He doesn't actually like you. Um he thinks that you're
annoying and that when you drink you get too much and that you're
always arguing and you're and you know and
yeah. So Prawn, personally me, I only I don't like you when you're
drunk. That's it. That's it. Um other than that, I'm cool with
you. Uh Prawn, I appreciate uh you um driving us around. You
win. Uh plant
sub.
Got another hour on the stream. Let's
Rock surgeon. Thank you for the sub. Another hour on the stream.
Let's go. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate you doing
like that. W
um who else? Who else is next? Um
Oil, she wasn't really I wouldn't say she's a part of the house,
but there's nothing negative I could say about oil. Oil's a angel.
Oil's hilarious. Honestly, she's too good for all those people.
And I'm glad she got far away because that place is a mess. That
place is a vortex. A cyclone. And I got drug in it. I mean, that
house is pretty
It's pretty disgusting in multiple ways. Yes. Metaphorically,
literally.
Yes. Yes. It's gross.
Yep. Clean your rooms, everybody.
Mick should go back to teaching kindergarteners. No, she shouldn't.
No. This is where Mick should be. right here doing this. Nothing
negative about her. Adri, let's talk about Adri. You know what's
funny, Adri? You sit here and talk about being a girl's girl
and talk about how you're so nice and
Adri catching heat. When in reality, when you're at home, you're
talking about how can I steal this idea? How can I steal this
idea? This isn't entertaining to watch. This isn't pretty. This
isn't that. And some of the I don't remember the girl's name,
but one of your friends you talk so much about. You talk about
your friends and you're talking idea and how you need to be the
first you need to be the first first person to do this and this
and this and I understand why Terry doesn't like you. Hey.
Oh, that was funny. Um.
Oh man, that's rough.
That's rough. Uhoh.
Adri, you're a
you're a Adri
You're a You're a So, go ahead and sit. Who told Murk? I almost
positive the person who told Murk was probably Adri.
Adri live reaction.
What you say me for? Is it 50 Cent?
I looked at the computer. The computer say Floyd say
I'm like what he say me for?
Yeah. Wow. Easy. You're going to shoot me. Say you have a gun.
I know how to handle guns, too. We're both from the same place.
Okay. We have that in common, but that's the only thing in common.
Adri, you're a and that's all you'll ever be. Thank you very
much. Um, so yeah, continue to pretend to be a girl's girl, you
know, pretend to be nice to other women when in reality, uh,
you drag women down behind the scenes and you and you want to
steal their ideas and you and you say you're a better creator
than everyone else. And God forbid, I'm not going to lie, you
talking about the whole misk thing, nobody cares anymore. So
let that go. Stop bringing it up. Stop dragging it up.
Oh [__] Who else can we talk about?
that did kind of happen. Cherry, what Porter Beller said that
Adrian came in the chat and you made a comment. I think I think
that's what happened. Oh, Danny. Everyone in the house. Sorry
to tell you. You're worried about Well, yeah. Danny knows that.
Danny's moved on. Danny has moved on with his life.
Yeah, Danny knows that. About me being transphobic, which I never
was. You need to be worried about everyone in that house hating
you and talking about how your parents take care of all of your
bills and your parents take care of this and your parents take
care of that and your parents take care of this and how you expected
everyone to take handle their furniture and and this and that.
Danny, everyone in that house hates you and talk nothing but
[__] about you. Um, Jesus Christ. Um, did I miss
anyone?
Did I miss any? I relevant. I relevant. I relevant. I relevant
a former.
Cool. So, yeah, but Danny doesn't live there either.
Go yourself. Uh, Adriana, go yourself. Legacy, go yourself. Squeeze
you.
Jokingly, [__] you. Um, who else? Uh, Prawn, W Prawn,
sorry you didn't get your verification. Uh, Wal. Uh, yeah, that's
about it. Okay, good
You know what's crazy?
I feel like
a chatter said this in chat once about how like Darius sucked
Murk's toes or some [__] and now I like I know what
they look like and it's just not a good visual. Uh, why? What's
wrong with those toes? cuz I don't I don't want I don't want
to know what anyone's feet look like, let alone alone like Darius
putting them in his mouth. Like that's just not something anyone
should realistically want. Okay.
All right. I just didn't know what was wrong with these toes
in particular. I think to suck generate and weird, but I just
wanted to know what Oh my god, I was so scared. I was so scared.
You were about to say based. Oh my god. Nope. Not saying that.
Not my not my cup of tea. Not my my heart dropped eggs. Okay.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. I don't think so, man. I
don't think so. Wait, Mr. Green Shirt, that's Frank, isn't it?
You're a freak. Okay. Okay. Well,
we got that stuff. I'm trying to think of what I'm covering next.
I actually don't know what I'm doing next.
We did another hour and I don't I don't even know. I'm not even
positive. Oh, I want to do that Piers panel. I think I will do
that Piers panel actually. Who's on it? Wait, what? Who's on
it? Um, it's uh Mirshimer and who is it here? I don't Shimer
and somebody else. Yeah, I know. Antonio Brown's wanted for murder.
Yep. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
I know that happened.
Uh, let's see
Where did I have this? Did I save this pierce thing? I don't
think I did. But Piers Mir Shimemer.
Yeah, John Mirshimer plus Ian Brener on Putin plus Israel. I
don't know. Maybe, maybe, maybe not. Yeah, probably just read
these court docs to be honest with you. The only thing is I don't
know if I read the previous ones. So I I just don't know if I
read the previous ones at all. I'll put a foot in my mouth, but
not a 7-Eleven hot dog. That's [__] up. Gummy verse.
What's wrong with a 7-Eleven hot dog, bro?
I will. Uh yeah, I guess I'll go.
Okay, thank you very much for coming on. That was awesome. Thank
you. Thank you so much for coming on. That was super cool. Enjoyed
it very much. Welcome. Welcome. And we'll talk to you later.
Yeah. Money by Monday. Goodbye, chat. Goodbye, chat. See you
later.